on va parler maintenant de conditions de
travail au bureau notamment très
populaire dans les années 80 des études
viennent remettre en question le modèle
du fameux open space dans les
entreprises et c'est la quotidienne qui
a enquêté comme 20% des français nous
travaillons en open space un modèle né
dans les années 60 avant tout pour une
question pratique et économique il
serait plus facile de communiquer avec
ses collègues dans un espace ouvert
qu'avec des bureaux individuels fermé
seulement voilà une nouvelle étude
américaine vient contredire ses idées
reçues 73% des changes en moins en open
space par rapport à des bureaux
cloisonnés en cause d'abord le silence
qui règne dans ces grands espaces mais
aussi le manque d'intimité qui
n'encourage pas les interactions entre
travailleurs mais revenir à des bureaux
fermés classique coûterait trop cher
pour beaucoup d'entreprises et dans
certains métiers où l'on travaille en
équipe ce n'est même pas envisageable
alors aujourd'hui certains réfléchissent
à des open space alternatif dans ces
nouveaux open space
les employés bouche d'un bureau à
l'autre avec leurs ordinateurs portables
au gré de leurs envies
alors il ya évidemment des fondations
été effectué auprès des français ya 36 %
des salariés qui travaillent en open
space 24% considèrent que leur
environnement de travail s'est dégradée
pour 82 % des salariés
un bureau fermé d'après eux permet une
meilleure concentration et enfin pour
50% des salariés un bureau fermé
favorise également la productivité ce
que vous êtes d'accord
vous aimez les vous travaillez à la
rédac en open space voilà en open space
avec cette mecque en jeu des garçons
voilà moi j'adore l'idée en plus on est
une espèce de famille c'est vrai qu'on
s'entend tous super bien mais du coup je
bosse avec cette mecque et c'est à une
soupe à la nana la plus raffinée du
monde a bondi
non non c'est pas ça donc j'ai pris
l'habitude un peu de noter des petites
phrases que on pouvait échanger qui
était un petit peu improbable je vous
vois venir vous allez balancer sur les
gars sûr que je peux encore très bien
alors j'ai un petit peu écrit mais parce
qu'il y avait certaines qui était
clairement un diffusable ah oui parce
que en même temps que je vous dis ça et
que je vous entends parler je me dis je
connais les garçons en question voilà je
suis pas certaine qu'à 17h54 pas ça mais
je suis même pas sûr qu à 22h23 j'en ai
deux pas mal j'ai je serai une meuf je
me toucherait les seins tout le temps
aulas alors laissez moi deviner ce
serait pas d'un producteur nourdine 500
salariés
[Applaudissements]
la deuxième tard péter ou c'est un reste
de tout
oui c'est vrai que c'est l'école
anglaise vous remarquerez qu est ce que
vous pensez donc mais est ce que malgré
tout normes ça favorise ça stimule la
productivité est ce que malgré tout
finalement il ya une ambiance qui fait
qui est tel que et ben on se concentre
un peu plus mais paradoxalement alors
que on est alors moi pour ma part je
trouve ça vraiment excellent chsr
brainstorm perpétuelle quand on prépare
les sujets on en discute les uns avec
les autres
en plus on s'entend extrêmement bien et
on rigole donc c'est quand même cool
d'affaires allemands le cas dans toutes
les entreprises coulent d'arriver au
travail en six ans il ya au moins un
moment dans la journée où je sais que je
vais avoir un fou rire et c'est vrai que
pour préparer une émission pour que les
gens s'amusent devant leur télé et
apprennent des choses c'est quand même
mieux pour nous en tout cas d'être en
open space d'accord pour le défigurer
dans le voilà d'après le supporter
mourir damien vous aussi au figaro vous
travaillez en opex mais oui
effectivement et je trouve que l'open
space quelque part celle arnaque du
siècle pourquoi parce qu'on nous a
présenté ça comme un moyen d'économie
certes pour l'employeur cessons de très
bien mais pour nous c'est vrai que c'est
très compliqué de nous concentrer parce
qu'on voit tout le temps des personnes
passé à côté de nous on a des bruits
parasites
moi j'ai un gros organes on me demande
de moins adéquat part d'un gros organe
vocal bien s'il avait un gros organise
un grand homme
on va voir la prétention tout le temps
de parler moins fort quand je fais des
interio les interviews c'est notre
métier et c'est vrai que je pense que
c'est pas nécessaire d'avoir un
open-space quand on a un mais quand on a
un travail affaire personnelle
évidemment dans une émission de
divertissement c'est un travail d'équipé
en permanence donc là pour le coup c'est
très utile et ça c'est pas stimulant
d'être dans un dans un truc un peu
ouverts comme ça où on voit les uns et
les autres travaillent et non ben non
finalement parce qu'en fait on ne s'en
veut plus des mails compte communique
par voie et du coup ça mais en fait il y
avait les deux aspects l'aspect patronat
c'était un réduction de l'espace de
travail et en même temps meilleure
surveillance
parce qu'en fait on sait que chacun
surveille l'autre s'il y en a un qui qui
glandent ça se dit c'est pas pareil que
l'univers des médias et l' avantage soit
disant pour les collaborateurs c'était
la communication l'interactivité etc
mais mais
je rends compte que c'est un vrai disant
moi je vais faire des interviews de
temps en temps dans certains journaux et
c'est compliqué de parler à un
journaliste pendant qu'il y en a deux
autres qui vous raconte son histoire
donc moyennement tatiana quelle horreur
valérie 100 % des français se flatte eu
le dessus vous êtes déjà un open space à
son très mauvais et les épidémies ça ça
commence où ça commence dans les open
space sont ceux tous dessus ont partagé
gastro entérite parce qu'on touche à
toutes les tables les uns les autres
d'accord passé médical de nationaux on a
essayé donner une permission quand on
l'a fait sortir de la clinique la
question de téléspectateurs à travailler
en open space est ce que vous estimez
que bah finalement c'est la bonne
ambiance qui prime aux biens il y a trop
de bruit trop de bruit pour se
concentrer à 63% effectivement ce que
vous disiez damien ça devient compliqué
de gérer saab son travail en open space
co